you know I only do this for you right
I'm not gonna get over here and drink
for anybody else I love it
good hey guys I'm Bryce ander this is
housewife's happy hour and Erika Girardi
is back hello my name what's Cheers
let's do this
here's to you here's to you oh thanks I
don't want to take off my are you
excited to be back oh sure I had a lot
of fun um did a lot of traveling and you
know obviously there are the usual bumps
in the road what's going to surprise us
about you and your life on the show this
year I think that you get to know me
Erika a little bit you know more
intimately and I mean I'm just a regular
person it was not fair Lisa it's not
easy to get you to crack I mean no no no
I hate it were you surprised that you
were driven to that place um I was
actually and I was driven there out of
frustration and just really just nothing
left l self give you know so yeah I was
kind of shocked that I did that myself
what was the reaction from the group
when you cried well we'll find out but I
think it was kind of like what is wrong
with homegirl yeah what happened her but
yes you know not my not my best moment
and we don't get to see it for a while
yeah you got to wait like you know we're
almost at the end on one of those trips
yes one of those legendary trips ever
criticized
that you don't know what I deal with
every night you give us any hint of what
when you're saying oh yeah well it's not
I don't think it's what people think it
is
I would I would assume most people jump
to something in your marriage or home
life yeah no not there you and Tom solid
as a rock
I should hope so we just celebrated 18
years together well congratulations
again that's really I'll drink to that
I'd need more drinking you know I do
drink to get through no I'm just gonna
get [ __ ] joking don't they good throws
like you did I did more than she did
cheers to season seven thanks baby do
them for you yeah that's so good to see
you yes yeah great mission accom I hate
you but not really it's great
you